are you still playing Ghost Recon
wildlands well it's set to receive a
huge patch that makes some noteworthy
additions to the third-person shooter
and I'm going to run you through
everything it changes adds and fixes I'm
Matt and this game spot news update is
taking a break from the head shots and
explosions to bring you the patch notes
the patch is already out on PC but ps4
and Xbox one players will have to wait
until March 23rd to get it for
themselves the biggest changes include
the ability to turn radios off by
default choose a type of vehicle that
spawns the drop vehicle skill and replay
a selection of missions that were
previously only playable once the PC
patch also sees the addition of the SMA
anti-aliasing mode as well as a
notification that recommends what type
of anti-aliasing would be best for
multiple GPU setups there are sure to be
more patches in the future so make sure
to LIKE and subscribe to be the first to
know when those make their way to the
game Ubisoft says that if you want to
continue playing co-op with your friends
everyone will need to be running the
same version of the game I mentioned
some of the bigger changes but there are
a bunch of fixes that I just can't fit
into one video so check out the rest of
them on GameSpot calm but if you want
some sweet tactics headshots and
explosions check out our video on the
things we wish we knew before starting
Ghost Recon wildlands
you